[Music]
on this Monday night the accelerating
covered 19 pandemic the World Health
Organization's new dire warning the
greatest threat we face now is not the
virus itself and why the worst-hit
country wants to slow down testing
Canada versus China and the charges
against the two Michaels we deplore it
why Prime Minister Trudeau is refusing
to do a prisoner swap another Canadian
shot dead by police
his family's desperate fight for answers
and feeling Zen in a den I really
enjoyed like actually sweating
the domes letting hot yoga enthusiast
feel right at home
global national with Donna freezing
reporting tonight
Robin Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us there's been a setback in
the fight against kovat 19 in many parts
of the world Canada and other countries
may be moving ahead with reopening
plants but the global picture shows the
pandemic is worse than ever
yesterday the World Health Organization
reported more than a hundred and
eighty-three thousand new cases around
the world that's the highest number of
cases recorded in a single day so many
of those cases are coming from two
regions Brazil seeing the biggest surge
reporting more than 34,000 new cases
today the total there now over a million
and the u.s. with more than 32,000 new
cases it's still the worst hit country
overall with more than two million cases
as Redmond Shannon reports tonight the
news comes as some countries show
worrying signs of a second wave there
was no masking emotions at Madrid
Airport as Spain finally ended its state
of emergency the tourism destination has
reopened its borders to most European
Union countries after three months that
saw almost 30,000 coronavirus deaths
progress in France on Monday - with kids
returning to school but as many
countries began to open up the worldwide
picture remains grim with a new record
of daily new cases and many of the
countries that had been doing well are
now showing signs of a second wave the
pandemic is still accelerating it took
more than three months for the first 1
million cases to be reported the last 1
million cases were reported in just
eight days almost half of the new cases
on Sunday came from Brazil and the US
alone with heavy death rates across
Latin America this coffin-maker in Peru
is barely able to keep up with the
demand violence broke out in Germany
when 700 people in an apartment block
were quarantined the country had been
doing a better job than many European
nations but the
productive number of the virus there is
now thought to be above two or even
close to three the our number needs to
stay below one to keep the spread in
check more than 1000 workers also tested
positive at this German meat processing
plants exclude even that Sahlin the
state premier says he won't rule out new
lockdown measures South Korea has been
one of the success stories of pandemic
management but officials say a small but
significant second wave has arrived much
earlier than expected South Korea with
other countries demonstrate that even
when you get down to very low incidence
you still have to a very strong Public
Health surveillance system South Korea
has managed to avoid full lock downs by
implementing a huge trace and test
program and relying on public adherence
to physical distancing measures Redman
Shannon Global News London in the US
where the first wave is still
accelerating some states are reporting
more cases among younger people who've
been congregating at bars and concerts
and there is more criticism of the
president tonight who joked that the US
should slow testing to bring the numbers
down Jennifer Johnson reports from coast
to coast new cases of kovat 19 are
breaking records dramatic spikes in over
two dozen states Florida hitting over
100,000 cases close to 3,200 deaths the
highest infection rates among young
adults crowding bars and beaches our
cases are shifting in a radical
direction younger a record for new cases
was set Saturday in California ICU beds
becoming scarce in Arizona in Texas some
counties are making masks mandatory
after Austin and San Antonio became two
of the five hot spots in the country
doctors angry after US President Donald
Trump suggested the numbers would go
down if testing was stopped potential
200,000 deaths by October is the number
it has overtaken everything including
homicide and suicide as the number one
cause of death in the last three months
so this is no joking matter
White House officials say the president
was joking but admit they are preparing
for another deadly wave we are filling
the stock
in anticipation of a possible problem in
the fall new york once the country's
epicenter has better news entering phase
two of its economic reopening hundreds
of thousands of people will be going
back to work experts say people need to
keep practicing prevention frequent
hand-washing physically distancing and
avoiding large crowds but the country's
lockdown has taken its toll longer that
you sit with that stress I mean that is
when we start seeing people come in with
you know debilitating panic attacks
researchers suggest getting outside but
keep your distance the new normal for a
country desperate to go back to the way
things used to be Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington
here at home there's some good news to
tell you about on the Cova 19 front
overall there were just 284 new cases
reported in the past 24 hours the
majority of cases are in Ontario which
reported 161 positive test results today
in that province there have been fewer
than 200 new cases in eight of the nine
past days and in Quebec there were 69
new cases but no new deaths for the
first time since March first a third
migrant worker has died from Cova 19 in
Ontario concerns over the health and
safety of these seasonal laborers
prompted Mexico to bar its citizens from
coming to work on Canadian farms but
Ottawa finally struck a deal with the
Mexican government to improve conditions
and allow migrant workers to keep coming
here
our Abigail Beeman spoke with Mexico's
ambassador to Canada who is optimistic
about the changes bunks separated by
cardboard in this video posted by
justice for migrant workers the farm
they named didn't respond to a request
for comment
the lease is increased because they are
not proper people staying in overdrive
mexico's ambassador to Canada tells
global news a big part of the new
agreement reached between the two
countries sees Canada stepping up
inspections and doing them in person the
Canadian government confirms in-person
inspections will start this week they
were put on hold in April last week
Mexico hit pause on the migrant worker
program leaving as many as 5,000
approved workers waiting now Juan Jose
Gomez Camacho says they're allowed in
due to the agreement that also sets up a
group that can respond immediately to
problems we are really we think we're
moving in the right direction the deal
also calls for sanctions for employers
who don't follow the rules and we are
ensuring that changes are made and that
there will be consequences frankly it's
very clear that the government is not
and is not able in responding to what is
a life in that situation the three
Mexican workers died in southwestern
Ontario where the outbreak is most acute
Monday premier Doug Ford announced
windsor-essex is the only part of the
province that won't proceed towards the
next phase of reopening largely blaming
farmers who won't send workers for tests
like I'm begging here for your support
for the people of the Windsor and Essex
what more you want me to do I just it's
frustrating to say the least sorry sorry
for going on but man everyone else was
cooperating in the whole province the
premier also promised new inspections of
migrants work and living conditions done
in cooperation with Ottawa and while
Ford says he can't force anyone to get
tested he did hint at taking stronger
measures if people don't cooperate
worried if the outbreak gets worse in
one part of the province it will spread
abigail Beeman global news Ottawa the
federal government is back at it with
China over the case of the two Michaels
the prime minister says it's clear
Michel Kovarik and Michel sport were
detained in an obvious attempt to put
political pressure on Ottawa over the
rest of Huawei executive mung Wong Joe
China strongly disagrees and has issued
Canada a warning our chief political
correspondent David akin is following
the increasingly bitter feud David well
Robin when China charged the two Michael
spavin Cove rig last week with spying
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau criticized
China for what he called their arbitrary
detention and he called the charges
disappointing those comments seem to
have hit a nerve in Beijing Tapan Tinchy
you'll win the recent erroneous remarks
made by the Canadian side clearly show
that Canada is applying double standards
on the so-called
judicial independence China's foreign
ministry spokesman said Monday there is
no such thing as arbitrary detention and
spokesperson Zhao Legion also said mungs
case in the case of the to Michels were
unrelated mendoza-denton Wang Wang Jo's
case is totally different from the case
of Canadian citizens anyone without
prejudice would know that clearly
Trudeau speaking hours later said it is
obvious the two cases are linked it has
been obvious from the beginning that
this was a political decision made by
the Chinese government and we deplore it
and Trudeau was emphatic when he was
asked if his government is considering a
trade of mung for the to Michels no
we're not considering that Canada has a
strong and independent justice system we
will ensure that it goes through its
proper forces and anyone who's
considering weakening our values or
weakening the independence of our
justice system doesn't understand the
importance of standing strong and our
principles and our values Canada also
got support Monday from key allies who
were speaking up against China's actions
US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo said
last week's charges of spying were quote
politically motivated and completely
groundless and he too is calling for the
immediate release of the two Michels
Robin
David akin in Ottawa Iran says it will
send the black boxes from that Ukraine
passenger plane it shot down in January
to France the strike killed all 176
people on board including 57 Canadians
Iran initially denied shooting down
flight 75 - but later acknowledged it
made a disastrous mistake a Toronto
police officer is facing a series of
charges in connection with an alleged
fraud scheme linked to the tow truck
industry constable Ronald Joseph was
first arrested a week ago charged with
breach of trust and theft he was taken
into custody again on Thursday on other
offenses including organized crime he's
accused of being part of an operation
that saw tow truck drivers get their
hands on encrypted police radios to get
information on collisions the Toronto
Police Service says Joseph took
kickbacks for providing insider
knowledge he used his position to steal
and transfer a police radio that would
give advantage to the group with respect
to the ability to intercept police
communications attend more accidents or
perhaps evade police detection Toronto
police have laid at least 50 charges
against a total of eleven people as a
result of the investigation
Joseph is suspended with pay the family
of an Ontario man who was shot dead by
police is demanding the officer involved
be immediately fired and a public
inquiry launched 60 chilled ages
Chowdhury was suffering from
schizophrenia and may have stopped
taking his medication his death has
sparked days of angry protests outside
the building where he lived and that's
where we find global Toronto's Sean
O'Shay tonight Sean Baba this protest
involves the shooting death of a 62 year
old man with mental illness it is the
second shooting of its kind since April
involving the same Police Department
anger and frustration stemming from the
latest death of a mentally ill man in
Mississauga 62 year old age as chaudhary
he was schizophrenic and he did have a
history of mental illness but I don't
think that was like he needed to be
killed for that he's like the
neighborhood uncle he would ask everyone
how you're doing you know he's a really
nice and sweet man and it's so sad to
see his life being taken away Peel
police responded to a call for help late
Saturday afternoon a report of a man in
crisis who was not taking his medication
arriving at Choudhary's residence
officers fired a Taser
then plastic projectiles then used
deadly force
police say Chowdhury had a knife but he
was alone in the apartment when police
burst in going in heavily armed and so
on and so forth not the way to go
criminology professor Rob Gordon says
the police approach here appears to make
no sense what are they thinking earlier
this month the same police force shot
and killed 26 year-old DeAndre Campbell
he also had schizophrenia family members
remembered him at an anti racism protest
this month Hill's Chief of Police
recently told global news there needs to
be a better job dealing with mental
health calls it's the opposite outcome
than what we ever took our oath to do
should there be a bolstering of other
systems so that I don't have to be or my
officers don't have to be at the
doorstep of people in a mental health
crisis a hundred percent community is
demanding answers insisting police be
forced to explain why they shot a man
dead was apparently only a threat to
himself that was a cold blood that's a
cold blood murder we want justice we
want whoever was whoever did what they
did to be held accountable it's
happening again and again and again and
the police are not being held at County
County ball for their action that
justice will have to wait as the
province of Special Investigations Unit
has now invoked their mandate meaning
this community may not have answers for
some time this case is now in the hands
of Ontario Special Investigations Unit
which looks into all police related
deaths but the community and the family
say they're not satisfied with anything
less than a public inquiry and the
officer being fired Robin Sean O'Shay in
Mississauga Ontario a noose one of the
most threatening images of America's
long history of racist violence was left
in the garage of Nascars only black
driver sparking an FBI investigation but
today there was a powerful moment
trackside as fellow drivers stood by
Bubba Wallace pushing him to the front
of the pack Wallace has been extremely
vocal in the wake of George Floyd's
death demanding justice
he's also the driving force that pushed
NASCAR to ban the confederate flag from
its facilities and events which went
into effect this
in a statement Wallace says the
despicable act of racism and hatred
leaves me incredibly saddened and serves
as a painful reminder of how much
further we have to go as a society and
how persistent we must be in the fight
against racism an explosive situation in
Nova Scotia
coming up when propane tanks become
projectiles a ball of flames lit up the
night sky in rural Nova Scotia after a
truck carrying hundreds of propane tanks
caught fire fire officials say the
flames reached as high as 20 meters as
the exploding tanks launched into the
nearby trees but they say the remote
location of the incident and that it
happened at a late hour likely saved
homes and lives no one was injured
including the two men in the truck who
got out in the nick of time in Quebec a
camp fire is believed to have sparked a
massive fire in that province the
aggressive out-of-control blaze is
burning north of Quebec City it has
burned more than 72 thousand hectares
and that's almost the size of Calgary
high winds and hot dry conditions are
fueling the flames more than 200
firefighters from Manitoba and Ontario
are being deployed to help and in
Arizona crews are trying to get the
upper hand on a huge fire near Tucson
the Big Horn blaze stretches more than
23,000 hectares and it's only 16 percent
contained evacuation orders are in
effect for surrounding areas several
other fires are burning across the state
including near Grand Canyon National
Park still ahead is it still too soon
for long-term care homes to get back on
track
as more long-term care homes are
declared virus free they're taking in
new residents to fill the hundreds of
beds left vacant by those who have died
from Coppa 19 but filling those empty
beds is opening up new concerns
Ross Lord explains after losing 17
residents took over 19 the Marke Haven
nursing home in Markham Ontario has
declared the outbreak over management
says it's refilling empty beds some
families oppose the move I think it's
too soon and I don't know what the plan
is
Cameron Robinson's mother Eileen lives
at Mark Haven he fears incoming
residents will bring infection with them
or detract from the care of others so
it's gonna take a lot of time and
without increased staff something is
gonna be sacrificed and my fear is it's
the resident scare it's gonna be my
mum's care mark Haven says new residents
will be forced to isolate for 14 days
the same rules for residents being
readmitted after hospital stays
management says it's very confident as
screening procedures noting the Ontario
government is providing extra funding to
allow for increased staffing but at a
devastating time for many long-term care
homes balancing residents numbers with
staffing levels is a big challenge with
keeping us up at night right now is we a
key word staff and long-term care right
now we're not sure that those who left
and are at home right now are gonna be
willing to come back the stigma is so
great this is critical labor unions say
it's understandable staff are reluctant
to rejoin the front line of the war
against the virus we've had workers who
have infected their spouses and their
spouses died and they have to live with
that from working in these nursing homes
so some of them are saying this just is
not worth it anymore some efforts are
paying off Quebec which leads Canada
with more than 5,000 covered 19 deaths
has been flooded with applications after
offering a generous wage package to
orderly's health care advocates say
paying others more across the country
would improve the odds of entering the
next phase successfully Ross lore Global
News Windsor Nova Scotia hot yoga
enthusiasts in Toronto now have a safe
space to practice
50 outdoor private domes have been put
up temperatures inside can exceed 38
degrees of course temperatures outside
are feeling about as hot with heat
warnings still in effect across the
region
the domes have received some backlash
many saying they should be used to house
the homeless instead up next the new
mystery at Stonehenge that goes back
more than 4,000 years
a huge announcement for all of our
viewers tonight two of America's
longest-running and most successful news
shows are coming to global is it true
general mattis said to you starting this
fall you'll be able to watch the
award-winning programs 60 minutes and 48
hours on Saturdays global will be the
new home for true crime when it airs 48
hours that will be followed by 60
minutes on Sundays which features
in-depth interviews and investigative
journalism Stonehenge is one of the most
studied prehistoric monuments in the
world and it's just yielded a new
discovery archaeologists have found a
huge ring of at least 20 ancient shafts
near the famous stone structure they
form a circle around it that's more than
2 kilometres in diameter the shafts were
discovered using remote sensing
technology it's believed they were dug
more than 4,500 years ago before
Stonehenge and could mark a sacred site
researchers say it's the largest
prehistoric monument ever discovered in
Britain and could shed new light on the
origins of Stonehenge and that is global
national for this Monday I'm Robin Gill
we leave you tonight with a delicious
treat or rather a delicious treat today
a winnipeg committee voted to keep
slurpy way for another two years
it's a tribute to the 7-eleven beverage
after all the frosty drink has sold more
in Winnipeg than anywhere else and the
city has been dubbed the world Slurpee
capitol thank you for watching Donna
freezin is back here tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]
[Applause]
you